bonsoir
ça va cada l'india cardinal est toujours
somptueuse vous avez déclaré vieillir ne
me dérange pas il n'y a rien de plus
triste que les femmes qui multiplie les
liftings penser que nous sommes le voit
que là ou bien tu parles alors ils sont
aveugles ou s'ils voient bien sûr moi je
vois de très loin ouais bon voix vous
n'avez pas fait en tous les cas merci
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que vous n'avez pas fait drifting que ça
se voit bien sur wii alors vous êtes une
star énorme fêtée partout vous dites
c'est le temps des récompenses et c'est
vrai que tous les festivals vous rendent
hommage cannes hollywood venise tout le
monde salue vos cinquante ans de
carrière mais vous n'étiez pas encore 50
49 ennemis 45 première gaffe ouais y en
aura d'autres qui rit
alors vous dites je ne veux pas entrer
au musée c'est vrai que vous ne serez
pas au musée au contraire vous monter
sur les planches puisque vous vous
revenez au théâtre à partir du 8 février
sur la scène du théâtre de la madeleine
dans une pièce de tennessee williams qui
s'appelle 12 oiseaux de jeunesse mise en
scène de philippe adrien avec vous
christophe raymond bernard verley alors
c'est l'histoire d'une star
vieillissante qui s'appelle princesse
qui riche et qui partage sa vie avec un
jeune acteur raté bon je crève de peur
je suis déjà morte je suis momifié
l'idée que dans deux semaines je vais
être là bas quoi moi j'ai toujours la
trouille j'ai toujours très peur ouais a
commencé les cauchemars oui cauchemar
c'est à dire que les autres non mais moi
ça fait même au cinéma j'arrive trois
heures avant les techniciens oui c'est
inox étiez là aujourd'hui vous étiez là
cet après midi vers la nettoyer
génial non mais c'est quoi l'histoire de
cette pièce c'est quand même intéressant
on n'avait pas hésité très intéressant
ce qui m'a fasciné c'est justement c'est
l'histoire d'une d'une star qui pensent
naturellement que son succès dépend de
la jeunesse dont elle commence à se
droguer à boire et complètement mais
alors folle rencontre ce jeune homme et
elle utilise un peu parce que ce qu'elle
aime c'est aussi faire l'amour ouais bon
moi c'est pas du tout c'est à dire moi
je suis pas du tout comme ça ah bon non
on annule
seul coup ça perd beaucoup de son
intérêt à faire dans ce sens que je suis
pas du tout une star à d'accord ok
qu'est ce que vous vouliez dire non à
vous tous si c'est ça alors oui je
voulais dire ça donc j'ai découvert le
théâtre à 60 ans avec une pièce
qu'ils s'appellent à vénissieux vous
devez dire toujours l'âge on met
d'accord je dis pas vous avez découvert
le théâtre la soixantaine ya quelques
années c'est pas exactement comme ça on
mai 2010 on peut dire on me dit claudio
voilà dans une pièce s'appelle la
vénitienne au théâtre du rond point
alors il y avait catherine allégret dans
cette pièce il ya quel âge mais pourquoi
vous dites toujours l'âge des femmes et
pas des hommes ben c'est un truc qui
nous a appris ce soir parce que
d'habitude en fait pas ça vous avez lu
le livre de catherine allégret oui vous
en avez pensé quoi écouter catherine moi
c'est quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup non
mais dis simplement sur l'a3 je suis
scandalisé
moi je crois que les gens sont libres de
dire ce qu'il pense ouais alors la vie
la vénitienne s'était déjà l'histoire
d'une femme d'un certain âge disons
qu'ils s'amouracher d'un certain jeune
homme un certain diront nous la
soixantaine quoi oui il ya aussi un
petit jeune ouais j'aurais petits
genevois stéphane meyer était là oui
non moi je suis pas toujours les petits
jeunes ont dansé avec john bien des
bien des années plus tôt visconti vous
avez proposé de faire du théâtre
l'époque vous pensiez vous mettiez pas
prêtre pourquoi bas d'abord avec mam n'a
voilà louis armstrong je pensais que
personne n'entendrait et puis
moi j'ai toujours très peur j'ai fait
plus de 150 films et pour moi c'est
toujours le premier way home cinéma vous
avez peur j'ai toujours peur et au
théâtre finalement c'est quoi qui vous a
décidé finalement à vous lancer parce
que bas parce que la caméra est quelque
chose de rigide et de froid tandis que
quand tu trouves de sur la scène tu sens
la respiration des gens parfois la laine
si au premier rang ça arrive
c'est bien joli de bettié
ya des gens qui pue de la gueule qui
vont au théâtre on peut lire
sur moi c'est pas ça que je voulais
bien quand vous racontez vous raconter
ça comment vous avez refusé de de faire
du théâtre à visconti ce que quand même
énorme strehler et puis deux et voilà
j'ai même refusé de faire une comédie
musicale à broadway ouais j'ai toujours
refusé
et vous raconter tout ça dans un livre
qui sort chez michel lafon qui s'appelle
les étoiles et qui parle de ceux qui ont
compté pour vous si ça vaut étoiles
c'est ceux qui ont compté pour toutes
les étoiles que j'ai rencontré le long
de ma carrière alors visconti fellini
sergio leone mastroianni bertrand
questeur john wayne brando enfin voilà
il y en a il y en a encore plein de la
queen games
alors j'ai lu votre bouquin claudia j'ai
trouvé ça très intéressant comme
histoire vraiment vraiment vraiment très
intéressant je vais essayer de faire
partager à mes amis que les spectateurs
là là l'intérêt que j'ai eue pour ce
livre absolument c'est très intéressant
dans ça commence à tunis un la naissance
la naissance à tunis puisque k o dia est
né en afrique comme tout le monde le
sait en quelle année
y'a pas d'années déjà fait planer sur la
fiche alors dites moi votre année 2500
58 58 ouais je suis un petit peu avant
vos parents sont nés en tunisie mais vos
grands parents étaient de purs sicilien
oui trois générations voilà on est
arrivés avant les français alors à
l'époque la tunisie était française est
pour beaucoup de français
l'italie reste et dites-vous un pays
fasciste alors il fallait faire profil
bas quand on était italiens en tunisie à
l'époque de votre naissance dire que
d'abord à l'école vous appelez pas
cardinal les néo cardinal
épi plaque claudio mais claude alors la
tunisie à l'époque était un protectorat
français mais il y avait l'indépendance
qui ce qui se profilait à l'horizon est
un garçon débarque là bas rené vautier
26 ans qui militait caméra au poing et
ils voulaient raconter la vie des marins
tunisiens
il n'arrivait pas à voir des femmes
tunisiennes dans son film et vous a
choisi oui j'étais une femme voilée et
puis le dernier plan de de ses
documentaires c'est un coup de vent et
là ça finit avec le gros plan le le film
a eu un très gros succès au festival de
berlin il a gagné tout ça voilà april a
été diffusée dans tous les cinémas de de
tunis et vous êtes devenu une célébrité
locale voilà juste à cause de ceux de ce
voile qui se soulève comme ça là à la
fin du film j'avais 15 ans est encore au
lycée ok le naissain ça suffit 1
[Rires]
c'est le destin c'est franchement non
oui mektoub mektoub là franchement
ensuite jacques baratier vous propose
gohelle simple que le premier film de
marc sharif lui il avait 24 ans et 17
comment il est et omar sharif est beau
très vite et marié à l'époque déjà j'en
sais rien moi je parlais pas j'étais une
sauvage un bon c'est pas que j'allais
discuter avec lui pour savoir s'était
marié ou pas ouais alors la même année
en 56 vous faites un concours de beauté
organisé par une italia qui tue le
concours de bush est pas en fait nous
fait pas le concours de beauté vous
élève mr dans la salle du concours de
beauté
vous vous occupez des billets de tombola
avec votre mère et c'est un concours qui
est organisé par une italia qu'à un peu
comme unifrance film ce qui fait la
promotion du cinéma italien à l'étranger
et à ce moment là quelqu'un me tire six
ans porte sur scène voilà et j'ai été
élue la plus belle italienne de tunisie
on m'a offert un voyage pendant le
festival de venise est le premier film
que je vois à venise ni blanche avec
visconti alors finalement vous accepté
la proposition de dunes italia de venir
à rome où j'allais à rome vous étudiez
le cinéma dans une dans une école vous
vous ennuyez un peu vous êtes un peu
dépressif qui est froid
mais pas que ça mais
non il n'y a pas que ça il avait aussi
l'autre histoire c'est à dire ce type à
la à la voiture noire
qui quand même occupé toujours votre
votre esprit non
il occupait pas mon esprit
mais en france c'était un peu une
angoisse ouais vous été violée à l'âge
de 16 ans par un français dont vous avez
toujours refusé de de dire le nom et
vous continuez à le voir malgré tout un
oui je voulais me punir c'était pour
vous punir ou alors parce que le fait de
continuer à le voir finalement c'était
plus un violent puisque vous continuiez
à le voir
c'était pour vous punir oui alors là
quand vous êtes assez dépressive ou
pensé au suicide à cette époque un
traîneau voilà et puis donc en 1958 vous
découvrez que vous êtes enceinte de ce
type vous refusé d'avorter vous repartez
à rome où vous signez un contrat avec
franco cristaldi qui est un producteur
important à l'époque en italie et là
vous tournez le pigeon de monicelli
qu'un film magnifique et un succès
colossal film avec mastroianni gassmann
totaux ouais et plus grandes stars de
l'époque quoi et là vous devenez en
quelques mois la petite fiancée de
l'italie quoi oui en plus je parlais pas
un mot d'italien
donc je comprenais rien avait
l'impression d'être sur mars sur la lune
et donc je parlais français à l'époque
en fait trois films là jusqu'au septième
mois de votre grossesse et à ce moment
là effectivement on pouvais plus tourner
parce que ça ça se voit terriblement et
la crystal difranco cristaldi vous
organise finalement un voyage à londres
en disant qu'à un projet ultra secret
dont on peut pas parler et vous aller
accoucher à londres et il vous ordonne
de dire que cet enfant n'est pas votre
fils mais votre frère et pendant des
années vous
vous raconterez ça vous aussi parce que
moi je ne fais pas que quand on signe un
contrat on était prisonnière non j'étais
très jeune j'avais 20 ans ce qui est
tout à fait notable dans votre histoire
cloud ya c'est que vous êtes soumises
dans un premier temps aux tipa la
voiture noire pour vous en échappée vous
allez à rome vous gardez votre enfance
qui vous honorent évidemment mais
ensuite vous devenez aussi très très
soumise à à franco cristal dessert vous
quittez une soumission pour une autre
mais le problème c'est que moi j'ai
accepté de faire du cinéma justement
pour affronter le problème moi même
est-ce que j'en avais parlé à personne
donc pour moi je vais à rome je fais un
contrat
voilà je pars vous avez du mal quand
même avec lui avec ce franco christelle
dit là parce que vous n'avez même pas à
vous dites pour raconter ça vous arrivez
pas l'appeler franco vous l'appelez
cristal dire que vous voulez admirer
mais vous l'aimez pas on voit bien
c'était c'était un homme très cultivé
très intelligent c'était le d'un des
producteurs le plus important d'europe 1
oui mais tu es très obsédé par son
travail aussi un oui vite que la seule
chose qui l'intéressait c'était son
immeuble avec ses bureaux
oui je pense
alors un jour vous décidé de dire la
vérité à votre fils qui prend le nom de
crystal dit puisque vous aviez épousé
entre-temps franco cristaldi atlanta que
c'est pas que je l' ai épousé c'est à
dire que ça a été un piège il avait tout
organisé moi j'étais pas au courant
oui un jour il arrive ça a tenté un
jouet la révision se marie ouais voilà
vous avez rien pu faire ben c'était déjà
tout organiser
mais le mariage n'a jamais été déclarée
autre part donc je me suis jamais mariés
voilà vous a été piégé un petit peu
affectivement et financièrement par ce
parce que ce talent d'une série parce
que je faisais quatre films par an je
gagnais des sommes folles et moi on me
paye et comme petit employé voilà et ça
je les fais pendant 17 ans alors vous
allez faire des tas de films entre 1958
et 1973 de les faire 50 films dont le
guépard huit et demi la viaccia la
panthère rose alors vous faites aussi le
plus grand cirque du monde avec rita
hayworth et il ya cette phrase terrible
c'est à dire qu'un jour vous la voyez
arriver sur le plateau était déjà assez
âgée elle picoler pas mal elle avait des
bleus sur la gueule et elle vous dit moi
aussi j'étais belle ouais ça a été
terrible terrible ça m'a fait pleurer
mais fais ce métier si tu est fragile il
vaut mieux ne pas le faire
vous faites aussi les professionnels
cartouches les pétroleuses et brigitte
bardot oui c'est très marrant ce que
vous racontez sur brigitte bardot parce
que en fait vous devez vous battre
contre elle et vous vous retrouvez en
train de vous battre contre un figurant
espagnol en fait un homme parce que
parce que moi j'ai toujours fait dans
tous les films tous les effets spéciaux
même trapet cheval tout parce que je
suis une grande sportive j'adore le
sport c'est un peu garçon manqué comme
je suis un gars au oui c'est d'en savoir
encore plus excitant musée
d'un coup et non parce que j'ai toujours
vous ne trouvez que c'est pas vrai que
les femmes sont faibles voilà c'est pour
ça que je me comportais comme ça et donc
vous battez avec ceux figurant
et puis au bout d'un moment on vous dit
c'est pas possible même battre contre un
mais qu'il avait des poils sur la
poitrine tout ça et vous allez voir
bardot et vous arrivez à la convaincre
c'est quand même génial de vraiment se
battre contre vous avez peur oui parce
que parce que tout le monde dit que
j'étais un mec que ben moi je m'entraîne
et je faisais de la boxe ouais ouais oui
j'ai tout fait athlétisme basket volley
tout mais là on s'est bien amusé et
alors vous lui avez fait mal non pas du
tout non une entente après mais non
parce que on s'était entraîné c'est à
dire quand tu donnes un coup de poing il
faut que tu bouges ton visage au même
moment un sens que tu le touches quoi
alors c'est fou parce que quand je lis
votre bouquin le nombre de mecs auquel
vous avez résisté ce extraordinaire
marcello mastroianni vraiment quitté
quand même le mec le plus séduisant du
monde quoi et il a d'ailleurs dit avant
sa mort j'ai toujours été amoureux
d'elle mais elle ne m'a jamais cru dire
qu'en fait il a passé sa vie à vous
déclarer son amour quoi vous y croyez
peut toujours pas là oui oui me l'a
toujours dit oui il ya toujours 10 mai
moi je suis pas du tout une femme facile
apparemment pas dans les pièges ouais
pourquoi vous pensez toujours c'est un
piège il peut être sincère le mc oui
mais moi je suis pas affolé pour les
flatter les aventures d'accord moi je
donne de l'importance à un rapport très
puissant très fort passion d'accord
c'est pas la femme d'un soir voilà n'ont
pas été grave il ya d'autres invités
sera pas
luc ferry alors vous avez résisté à
marcello mastroianni à brando comme
extraordinaire quand même la scène avec
brando et erin votre bouquin vous
marchez vers lui vous regardez comme ça
il a eu tout le monde brando il a eu
marre et une bonne rogers actuellement
et ils vous voient arriver et vous vous
juger comme ça en plus c'était dans ma
suite au belge louis charles quand je
tournais là bas donc il est monté il a
fait tout son humour a acc torse tout
dur et il savait très bien que pour moi
lui c'était un mythe parce que c'était
mon acteur ça toujours été un acteur
préféré
mais ça été amusant parce que on s'est
regardé après qu'il a fait tout son
numéro et
et on s'est mis à rire il m'a dit voilà
j'ai compris tu es bélier chez bélier
attend pas d'empiler d'illange tombe pas
à toi 15 avril 18 rebonds quelle année
[Musique]
j'ai 65 ans
quand on parle pas obsédé par l'âge
donc vous avez résisté à marcello
mastroianni à marlon brando et à de niro
vous savez dans la vie
quand y'a un mec qui te court après et
que tu ne regardes pas il continue à te
courir après si tu dis oui
à chasser les gonzesses que tu peux
jamais sauté tu tu vois le genre ça
c'est les gonzesses du midi du sud de
l'italie à elles sont comme ça le regard
dédaigneux que portent les filles comme
vous sur un mec qui veulent et ce au tcs
voit là badaboum le fait lorsqu'elle
voit que
ça m'énerve bon alors vous résister à
tout le monde mais quand même elle cède
quand même pas mal elle cède à un moment
elle ça joue en 72 vous cédez à pasquale
squitieri squitieri vous voulez faire le
film et celui qui veut pas il veut pas
parce que le pas et vous n'est pas une
star voilà des stars
et ça ça vous excite et sa non parce que
bon il est d'abord très beau et donc
j'ai décidé que c'était lui c'est tout
mais qu'est ce qu'il avait de plus que
les étés très beau et bien de le dire
d'accord on va marcello mastroianni et
marlon brando et robert de niro y sont
très boisée près parce qu'on était mieux
à mieux ouais
voilà ça tient plus il était un
fou déchaîné 1 j'aime les fous fait un
homme
s'est vraiment fait ce qu'il a nommé
dick nous on va faire pareil mais non je
vais vous le dire en tous les cas vous
poursuivez jusqu'à new york oui vous qui
avez été tellement fier toute votre vie
avec les mecs d'un seul coup vous c'est
vous qui le harcelaient quoi oui hein
parce que j'avais décidé que c'était lui
ah ouais d'accord donc je suis arrivé
avec ma petite valise à new york je sais
même pas où il était j'ai passé un coup
de téléphone un copain mois là et il
était là alors j'ai dit je suis à new
york il a failli s'évanouir est ce que
tu viens faire si tu atteins bien
l'aéroport voilà voilà il est venu il
est venu depuis ça dure trente ans un à
un ses biens
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'à ce moment là votre producteur
la franco cristaldi vous pensez qu'il
était détaché qu'il allait se montrer
compréhensif pas du tout il rentre dans
une colère noire il vous flingue dans le
métier paris des seuils est-ce que je
juge bien sûr j'annule le contraint
surmontera et tout ça et je me retrouve
avec des centaines de millions de
d'impôt à payer parce qu'ils n'avaient
même pas payer des impôts alors que moi
j'étais payé trois fois rien voilà ce
qui est terrible c'est qu'à cette époque
là même visconti à un moment et je vais
vous prendre dans l'innocent et et vous
prend pas parce qu'il est pote avec
franco christelle dit c'est à dire que
là d'un seul coup c'est dur dans ces
conneries oui parce que c'était le plus
grand producteur
mais bon avec luchino on a toujours eu
un rapport absolument extraordinaire
c'est à dire ça nous a pas empêchés de
voyager ensemble et de et d'être très
uni
[Musique]
alors qu'à audiard on l'a vu vous êtes
très très italienne donc on va vous
faire une interview [ __ ]
[Musique]
yao jian est ce que comme une vraie
italienne vous êtes jalouses non est ce
que comme une vraie italienne vous aimez
bien les machos
j'aime les foules et les mecs oui est ce
que comme une vraie italienne êtes
possessive avec votre fils pas du tout
ah oui pas dit il fait ce qu'il veut moi
mes enfants ils ont vécu tout seul à 14
ans je l'arrêt des toute la liberté
parce que je suis une femme libre moi
c'est pas un peu tard à 14 en
bas je pensais que c'était bien est ce
que comme une vraie italienne vous
faites sécher votre linge au balcon
non c'est comme une brique à lienz est
fier de vos rondeurs de miranda mais je
suis pas ronde est ce qu est ce que
comme une vraie italienne vous êtes
laissé un petit peu aller quand vous
avez été marié même si jamais marié
d'abord et c'est comme une loi italienne
où manger des pâtes tous les jours non
je mange très peu je marche comme un
petit oiseau est ce que comme une vraie
italien nous est croyante riche et
catholique est-ce que vous finissez
toutes vos phrases par vaffanculo non ça
je peux le dire n'a pas trouvé c'est pas
habituel quoi c'est pas et c'est comme
une vraie italienne où un membre de la
famille dans la mafia
non non vous avez un grand frère qui est
un peu trop protecteur non non c'est moi
la plus grande d'accord donc c'est moi
qui l'ait comme ça est ce que comme une
brute aliens que le stade le dimanche
j'adore le foot est ce que comme une
brique aliens vous tombez descamps vous
bousculent dans la surface de réparation
non je tombe pas et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de in a l'habitude abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux